why do you say limit physical evidence
to three to five pieces I do I do say
they're a lot there are
six basic types of evidence
in the world that you can use not just
for writers but for invest real
investigators and physical evidence
there are three types of physical
evidence
physical evidence
is especially DNA because we've come so
far with DNA right now I first of all my
rule of thumb is never solve a case with
DNA
that was okay in the 90s when DNA was
evolving and it was like this bright
shiny new thing but now it's too easy
and DNA is just to go it's so good so
um that will which is too easy I think
for story story wise
and I say limit to your
overall physical evidence three to five
because while those are interesting
Trails of evidence and we need them to
connect the dots to from our crime to
our Criminal
they're not they can a lot of times they
can be easily resolved uh because you're
you know you're looking at tangent Like
A Shard of glass okay of course
eventually they're gonna find out okay
it's this kind of glass and it came from
that window at that church on that
street okay great we connected those
dots awesome but what's more interesting
story wise is circumstantial evidence
and that's all that indirect evidence
what people think or hear or or infer
it's that gray area and if you look at
like we'll go back to sharp objects most
of that is solved through circumstantial
evidence
piecing together memories piecing
together where people were at certain
times piecing together what people said
or heard or what is it's not it's
there's a there are physical pieces of
evidence but it's it's mostly
connected through circumstantial
evidence and
I think that's what makes
for good tension because and suspense
and gray area in story
and
unless you're writing a very
um a very straight forensic kind of
story type which is great I mean we have
those and we we all love them
um bones is a great example of that CSI
and NCIS those are really fun and
they've been on the air forever they're
Classics and but they deal very strongly
in in physical evidence but I think that
the circumstantial that other gray area
is
really interesting to play around with
with your characters
and
that's why I say try to limit your
physical evidence and really focus on
pulling out character
and how character plays into
um creating your Trails of evidence
if that makes sense is is direct
evidence the same as physical evidence
direct is
things like photographs video witness
testimony it's not really physical
evidence it's not really circumstantial
evidence
uh so
videos photographs those are fun to use
but they're pretty they're direct right
they're pretty this is what you get if
somebody videotapes somebody doing
something well it's pretty hard to
dispute that unless you you know can
figure out some ways to trip that up
witness testimony can be very gray or it
can be very clear you can really play it
both ways so what about hearsay let's
suppose you have a small town
everybody's got their own agenda
small towns are filled with gossip right
and everybody kind of has their own
angle whether it's positive or negative
right where does hearsay fall into that
yeah that would be more circumstantial
type of evidence what people are
inferring
um what their sort of concluding based
on
you know whatever biases or things they
think they have seen or heard or you
know so but I love it that's definitely
uh what should be happening in your
Mysteries
um broad church I don't know if you know
this British series and then they made
it into a U.S series and I can never
remember the name of the US one uh that
really plays a lot on
that what you just said that to
everybody's got a different angle in
town and a different I saw this and I
did this and he said this and
um that's fun a lot of fun
or Mysteries better served in a small
town environment
I
don't think it matters
I think again it's
setting it's tone
um
we can have very
well okay I'll say this because I'm from
a small town so I'm very impartial to
small small town Mysteries because of
exactly what we were just talking about
with the circumstantial and the hearsay
and
um people are very tightly connected a
lot of times in small towns and
um
it's hard
it's harder to be inconspicuous it's
harder to hide things in a small town
you are known
so that's a whole one element to play
with in terms of if you what kind of
setting and tone you're giving your
mystery in bigger cities it's easy to
disappear it's easy to be incons you
know just to hide away and nobody knows
you it's
um it's so that's a whole different
right tone and setting and but also
there's
I don't know it's that that lends its
own kind of interesting mystery right
because you could be as a killer you
could be killing a lot of people in a
big city and it could take a long time
before somebody caught you because
you're an unknown
um whereas in a small town it's harder
to hide from that sort of behavior I
guess so it probably just depends too
like what kind of crime do you want to
explore
um
it's of course bigger cities you're
dealing you can deal deal with bigger
crimes in terms of like
a criminal World a bigger criminal world
like Mafia or a gambling ring whereas in
a smaller town that's going to be harder
to hide it's still happening probably
but it's going to be a little trickier
to hide that to hide a mafia ring in a
small town although maybe there's
something to that maybe there should be
a show about that
hmm
like uh the Crawdad movie did you see I
did see that yeah and I thought that was
really interesting because she couldn't
there were all these rumors about the
quote-unquote marsh girl yeah yeah true
or untrue and and so it was just I
thought that was a great yeah and and
some of the the best scenes were her
just kind of like stormy through town
yeah and um the the
shopkeepers you know crating their neck
and things like that to see oh there she
is you know right yeah this little fish
out of water and everybody's got their
thoughts and theories about her and I
guess that would really be a caper it's
that story because we are rooting for
our criminal the entire time
mm-hmm
don't want to give spoilers away too bad
if you haven't seen it by now or read
the book
I've heard it's 30 years and then you
can give away 30. oh no that's too long
okay how did digital forensics factor
into storytelling
I know this is great question I've been
actually exploring this whole world of
digital forensics for a while because
again it's really emerged as a sign of
science a thing in the real world within
the last 10 years and become you know
electronic forensics be it's very huge
field now especially with identity theft
and all that I think it's how do we
explore that I think it's challenging
because again like it's all happening on
screen or inside of a computer code
right and Visually it's just not that
exciting to watch so I think it has to
you know whatever
and also a lot a lot of people me
include I don't understand coding I
don't understand how criminal I don't
understand that world of criminal
activity I don't because I don't know
I'm not a computer scientist I never
studied computers science I never
studied coding I don't know how to do
any of that so and a lot of people don't
so that knowledge is something then as a
writer if you're going to draw us into
that world you're going to have to make
it accessible to us and you're going to
really have to rely on the characters
stories at this point in history anyway
you know where we're at now this may be
different in 10 years but
it has to really still go back to the
very strong basics of story and your
hero and your antagonist and really
showing us
what they are doing how they are doing
it and the stakes and that is an
interesting challenge when the whole
world of that is inside a computer right
and a microchip or on a inside on a
screen so I I haven't figured this out
quite yet how to make that completely
interesting
in terms of if that were your whole
criminal world I think Hollywood's
probably still figuring it out because I
haven't seen any shows or a lot of
movies that I can even pinpoint that
that were that's the focus that's the
main crime solving Focus even though in
the real world that's people's entire
jobs is just to break down criminals on
the web or dark web or wherever
um so
it's a huge
huge growing
criminal world that's out there in
reality
I'm curious to see how we've
translated that
to a fictional World
um yeah that's
I'm waiting to see also phones
geolocation
and and you know you said you talked
about you know
circumstantial evidence of someone's
location well now if someone's phone
pinged a certain Tower maybe they had
them phone in their possession and like
that yeah that's that's um definitely
see a lot of that like using
technology or people's technology to
track them or to track a killer or
figure out their last steps in life
where were they like that definitely
yeah that's used all the time and
um again that's
I guess I would call that physical
evidence
um because it's very tangible it's very
maybe it's a combination of physical and
direct and so it's really easy to prove
right like oh their phone was here and
this Tower is here these are all
tangible very real things so again like
use them sparingly
of the 11 types of crime stories
which is the most difficult to write and
why I just think that depends on who you
are because they all are very there's
like legal there's paranormal there's
medical mystery there's
um
profiler I think I said before
traditional cop the Caper I'm missing a
few but it really depends on what kind
if you're creating this it depends on
what kind of world do you want to live
in like I don't love the legal world I
don't love watching legal shows I don't
really know a lot about I don't like
care too much about that legal world so
I will for me that would be really hard
if someone was like write a legal crime
drama I'd be like so much research ah um
I just I just doesn't thrill me
um
so it really just has to depend it
really just depends on who the person is
creating it and what kind of world they
really want to spend time in
um like the medical examiner uh
investigation Corner that's a whole
nother Crime Story type with shows like
Rizzoli and Isles and Quincy and I I
feel very comfortable in that world
because I lived that world so but where
someone else might be like oh like
that's not the world for me so I think
it just depends on
what world do you want to spend time in
yeah
what happens when you get stuck in a
story how do you get yourself unstuck
whether it's a novel screenplay
I research
I take a shower I take a walk I call a
friend
I
I let it rest sometimes and I do maybe
go do something else for a while and
I can say that it always how any one of
those options gets me unstuck
yeah I've never been yeah if I try it
yeah so I just have to try something and
it will work I know it will work
so it's good to have hobbies that are
you know if you're writing about sort of
a Dark World maybe hobbies that are a
little lighter and fun and you said you
like comedies yeah I think so I mean
even something as simple as like I'll
just like I don't know
go vacuum or so you're just doing
something completely different than that
you're not thinking about the story
um but yeah when I unwind I mean I love
I love to read I read a lot of
non-fiction I love I've been getting
more into reading more crime fiction
um rather than viewing so much and so I
do love
to be in that genre just to stay up in
what's what's happening and what are the
new stories and but honestly in my spare
time I'm going to put a comedy on 100 of
the time
I'm gonna watch Ted lasso over and over